and that was not god
they took them out of the school
they took them out of parliament
they took them out of every every
establishment
and no wonder we have to come here
no wonder we have to come here and stand
together in unity
hallelujah
so now we're going to pray
the lord's prayer in my daily language
i'm going to pray
and then you're going to say it with me
in faith believing god
to change this country
in jesus precious and holy name
amen
our father
who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come
thy will be done on earth
as it is in heaven
give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses
as we forgive those who trespass against
us
and lead us not
into temptation
but deliver us from evil
for this the kingdom
the power
the glory
are yours
now
and forever
[Applause]
[Music]
to jesus
amen i have demanded that they bring
back
the lord's prayer in schools
i am set apart for the lord to make this
happen
[Applause]
thank you for agreeing with me
amen in jesus name my name is ginny
bruno i wrote a book to get water on
first nations reserves
and you know what
i need funding for that book it's called
we were much more than porridge
and you know what i come here today to
fix the water situation on first nations
reserves i have a plan
you want to help me
you want to help me find that book it's
only 3 500
because i'm
because um christian faith publishing is
going to take it up they even said it
could be a movie
so
my email you want to contact me jenny
bruno gmail.com
g-i-n-n-y
bruno
v-r-u-n-e-a-u
gmail.com
thank you so much god bless you busted
chuck
bring the lord's prayer back to the
school
oh he's from fake news
you're a hero
[Applause]
good afternoon canada
i suspect this will be the sweetest
anthem we have ever saw
here's our flight
our home and native land
true
patriot love
in all thy sons command
with glowing heart we see
thee rise the true north strong and free
from far and wide o
canada we stand on guard for thee
god
keep our land
glorious and free
o
canada
we stand on guard
for
the
oh
canada
we stand on guard
for
thee
[Applause]
please sing with me
how
sweet the
sound
that
saved a
wretch
like me
i
was
lost
but now
i'm found
was blind
but
now
i see
[Music]
twas
grace that taught
my heart to fear
and embrace
my
fears really
i'll pray
did
that
grace appear
the
our
i
first believed
[Music]
through many
dangers toils
and snares
i have
[Music]
thus far
and
grace will
lead me
home
the
lord has
good
to me
his word my hope secures
[Music]
[Music]
as
long as life
is
[Music]
and when
this flesh
and heart shall fail
and
more
life
shall cease
i shall
possess
within
a life
of joy and peace
when
we've been there ten
thousand years
bright shining
as
the sun
we've no
last days
to
sing god's praise
then
when we first
[Music]
we need a medic over here a medic please
medic please over here
do we have a medic
praying folks in the crowd please start
praying don't know what's happening but
can we please get a medic over here by
the post
no don't move people if you move you're
going to cause more commotion
back up people back up back up
father god we don't know what's going on
here
but god we pray for this situation
god for whatever is going on that you
will
help the medics in this situation god
help this person
in their pain and their sorrow and
whatever is happening god
if we can let the police in they're over
here guys over here there's police
what do you need please park let's clear
away please for the piece but don't
don't
don't get in the way though
[Music]
like me
i
was lost
[Music]
[Music]
amen god bless you guys god bless these
uh people who are helping this lady
pray for her
guys thank you so much for allowing me
this opportunity my name is chris burke
i'm a pastor from prince edward island
so happy to be here worshiping with you
guys today i'm happy to hand these
things over
to pastor henry hildebrandt
[Applause]
just a reminder
just a reminder pastor hillebrand has
suffered a lot in this country for
having a voice
and speaking on behalf of all of us and
praying on behalf of all of us
it's our honor to have him here
although he believes it's his honor to
be here in our presence
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
convoy
2022
has arrived in ottawa
[Applause]
we will we will now first pray for this
lady over here
father we ask that you would help in a
special way lord you see this lady here
that needs your help lord we ask that
you would undertake father you are able
to do it dear father help her dear god
lord you see her body you see what her
weaknesses lord we ask that you would
undertake and help father we thank you
we thank you that you're able to do that
and lord we're looking to you to do that
father in jesus holy name we pray amen
i have the
mighty privilege to have pastor
carlos norbell here with me from quebec
he will also be my french translator
we are
good friends close friends i thank god
for him
father we bless your name
we proclaim your justice we proclaim
righteousness in this land
we speak blessings oh god in this convoy
of truckers that came from
all over the country
father we pray that you hear our cry
as we lift up our voices to you
we pray that the plans of the enemy and
the plans of darkness will be
extinguished in the name of jesus christ
father we pray for strength
we pray for health
we pray for blessings
we pray for advancement
and we pray oh god as you promised you
will build your church and the gates of
hell shall not prevail against it father
we stand together with one another
claiming oh god this land is a land of
freedom this land is a land of
prosperity this land is a land o god of
faith and joy we pray in jesus mighty
name that the barriers that the enemy
wants to establish in this land begin to
[Applause]
we pray for an awakening socially
politically let people come together and
see truth stand for truth and go for
truth
it's in the mightiest name of all that
we pray the name of jesus christ the
king of kings amen and amen
[Applause]
we are so proud of you truckers
truckers you did it
you did it
[Applause]
we labored we fought but we could not
get it to this level and truckers you
brought this to a brand new level
thank you thank you
[Music]
this is
this is the largest fringe
minority about people i've ever seen
within our canadian constitution
and the bill of rights
and most importantly
most importantly the unfoldable word of
god
[Music]
this large
this large fringe
that has gathered here from every
province of canada and the territories
was greeted and welcomed by thousands of
freedom
[Applause]
i say canadians capital letters
that line the bridges and overpasses in
every town
and city
this fringe
i keep using that you know why
this bridge
it's all inclusive
it is family oriented
[Applause]
we do this today
not just
[Applause]
if it looks like i'm mad i'm just
passionate don't worry about it
[Applause]
it is family-oriented
without discrimination
without discrimination based on race
national or ethnic origin
color
or religion
[Applause]
constitutional
[Applause]
have your freedom god given freedom
[Applause]
can they just have the freedom to feed
their children
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
mr prime minister
your words of division
and contempt
are contrary to the very foundation of
our beautiful country canada
[Applause]
[Music]
south
he's in hiding right now in this south
tower
you see our peace tower
look at that peace tower over there in
the south window of our peace tower
i stress peace tower
we have these beautiful words engraved
in the window of that south peace tower
i'll read you the words
you know what it says truckers this is a
real encouragement for you thank you for
coming sacrificing
your time and families coming here
[Applause]
you say
i didn't know that's what it says there
no i'm ready to say it now what it says
there
it says there
freedom
is the sure possession
of those alone who have the courage to
defend it
[Applause]
look
in that window
in that wind on the south wind of the
peace tower it says freedom is the sure
possession of those alone who have the
courage to defend it
[Applause]
pastor shouldn't you be preaching jesus
yes
god given freedom
[Applause]
mr prime minister
in canada
everyone has the following
fundamental freedoms
freedom of conscience and religion
freedom of thought
belief opinion and expression
freedom of thought
belief opinion and expression
including freedom of the press
and other media communication
freedom of peaceful assembly and freedom
of association
[Music]
[Applause]
first corinthians
chapter 3
verse 11
first corinthians chapter 3 verse 11
says
for other foundation
can no man lay
then that which is laid which is
jesus christ
[Applause]
can i make a bold statement this
[Applause]
i'm not waiting for them to bring god
back to parliament we'll do it
in jesus name and with the help of these
truckers
we are bringing god back to parliament
[Applause]
we are bringing
the bible back to parliament right here
this is our foundation
when you get off the foundation it will
go well
folks dad let's get back to the
[Applause]
the
bible
[Music]
is not politics no no
[Applause]
we are not short on politicians
we are short on people in government
that remember the foundation
[Applause]
we are short on people that recognize
the importance of it
every single politician
in this parliament
must study the 25 bible verses that are
engraved in that parliament building
25 bible verses are engraved in that
parliament building and they don't want
to hear a pastor forget
[Applause]
we that get back if we want to do good
if we want to have success
on the roof let's teach the politicians
get back to the bible
just reminding them of our foundation
if you take the house off the foundation
it will sink
and these truckers i've been moved to
tears these truckers have been honking
and honking you know what that honking
means
we want our freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
just a word
just a word to our prime minister
if you don't want to heed to the word of
god if you don't want to heed to the 25
bible verses that are engraved
you might have a fringe coming to ottawa
and knock on your door
[Music]
i always heard i always heard that he
really cares for the minorities i guess
this is too large for him
we the people
we the people all we want from our
government officials our stress all we
want from our government officials is we
want them to uphold the constitution
they're up here for a reason they may as
well help me
all we want is for the government
officials to uphold the constitution
to uphold the bill of rights
[Music]
and most of all turn this way and most
of all we want them to uphold
the word of
[Applause]
god out of everything
[Music]
[Applause]
all we want
all we want is that they recognize and i
quote their own words all we want is
them to recognize the supremacy of god
that's all
hello
and if you do that if you recognize the
supremacy of god you won't jail the
pastors
find the pastors
[Applause]
the call
is to get back on the foundation we
won't negotiate ourselves out of this
mass
we won't negotiate ourselves out of this
what we need is get back on the
foundation that's all
king of eternal glory mr prime minister
there is a very fitting word of advice
for your present situation
i hope
i hope that all the truckers can hear me
because in great of a great respect and
honor to the truckers i'm addressing the
prime minister and telling him i will
have some advice for him you know what
that is
in great respect i look at those trucks
how does that say in gold if you've got
it the truck brought it
so mr prime minister and i didn't get to
finish that yet here i'll start again mr
prime minister sorry
don't bite the hand that feeds you but
instead
deal yourself a hand that will stop you
from getting hit [ __ ] sorry stop you
from getting bit by your mind
[Applause]
[Music]
for
[Applause]
[Music]
god has not given us the spirit of fear
but of power
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in my heart
[Music]
okay
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so
we're gonna go on the hill
we're gonna try and go a little bit from
the back
no i'm going around
[Music]
let's set in the communism
[Music]
we're getting it
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
yesterday with us
[Music]
buddy
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like crazy
controversy somebody put on a piece of
paper
on the terry frank statue that says
mandate freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
do you really think that terry fox would
be against the basic freedoms
that allowed him to run across country
which
[Applause]
the greatest this is
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Applause]
i live this morning several years
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right
just watch your ankle here
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the biggest block party in canada
how did you put together
such a peaceful
gathering in ontario which is only
starting today by the way they think
we're going to be out of here in a
couple of days
[Applause]
but the reason it's so peaceful
is because of the canadian spirit
and because of this woman's spirit and
positive energy
[Applause]
that's all i want to say for now we're
going to be having a news conference
later on
i want to hand it over to tamara
say a couple of words
she needs some encouragement she needs a
great big applause
[Applause]
[Applause]
so glad to see all
i've been doing a lot of lives i don't
know if i have any more tears left to
cry but i think you've all seen me cry
just about every day for the last two
weeks
and that's okay i've said many times
that we have to come together now
and we're going to have to heal after
all this is over
but to see all of you here
as one
refusing to be divided by race or
culture or faith or beliefs anymore or
geography
right
we are all canadian citizens
bye
you might as well try it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna go through again yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
many
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't have a keyboard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you